if you remember what he says in one of
his videos how he scammed them out of
their twenty thirty percent oh I I need
you to sign this tax form so yeah I'm
going to pay your taxes but he takes
another chunk of their money that's
another form of fraud so he says he's
innocent he says he's never said that go
to the club he's telling people what he
has done and there's evidence to
corroborate what he's done and when
you've got these manuals of how to do
this and how to coerce women and then
you've got a whole host of women they're
saying he did this to me I've got the
tattoo to prove it I've been locked in
there I've had to give him all the money
and even going back to the BBC interview
he did recently he actually says in that
interview I'm not going to incriminate
myself and you're like how can you
incriminate yourself if you're innocent
and then he's comparing himself in this
video too Johnny Depp world famous actor
Cristiano Ronaldo world famous soccer
player and you're like me you're a
glorified pimp who made your business as
that several people have accused you
it's not one girlfriend gone wrong in
that 80 page order is the most damning
they have way more than they need to
prosecute